i have been playing an early build of
baldur's gate 3 for over
15 hours now which may have been enough
time to see most of the early access
content if i weren't switching back and
forth between runs
or creating new characters so often
after being so excited to play bg3
and being drip fed content over the past
year or so i was certainly full of
anticipation to jump into the world and
while i had high hopes that the
storytelling and systemic gameplay was
going to be interesting to play with
and attempt to break i didn't expect
baldur's gate 3 to address one of my
deepest pet peeves in rpgs
and that's how the genre handles failure
in boulder's gate 3
failure actually becomes fun let me
start by saying even in the face of the
early access bugs and glitches the game
both plays and looks great
and as someone who's gone through a
bunch of real-life dnd campaigns seeing
a lot of those table top elements come
to life
really is incredible but i'm here to
talk about narrative
and story today now there are a few ways
that some of my favorite role-playing
games have handled bumps in the road or
failures or end states in their quests
take fallout for example when you are
teased with a prospect of a dialogue
choice in the conversation box but you
don't have the relevant stat
so you're left thinking what if i were
able to select the option but in many
cases never getting the chance
to basically failing at the first hurdle
other games address any failure to
adhere to the quest line with an
unsatisfactory full stop
basically cutting that story thread
there and then taking that as a yep
you failed that's the end of that but
you know better luck next time
but baldur's gate 3 immediately felt
like a different beast with how it
handles its narrative
story beats and the options that are
available to the player
in my first hours i tried to resist the
urge to save and reload if i failed
dialogue options or dice rolls and i
honestly
recommend you resist that same desire
despite how tempting it may be
in fact doing so may mean you'll miss
out on much of the ebb and flow
of some of the dialogues and smaller
stories within the early access build
failure and booked up dice rolls are
just as important to the story and
development of your character
and overall experience as successes and
natural 20s are
while i know it's fun to see the word
success pop up on your screen as you
roll well
i've come to realize that in boulder's
gate 3 at least a video game where i
only succeed
isn't what i want and it really isn't
representative of the tabletop game that
it's built upon
in this way bg3 really is an extension
of the dungeons and dragons
tabletop storytelling because no matter
your build your stats
all the choices you make the chances of
failing are
never zero and your success is never
guaranteed
in that way it's up to the players to
figure out creative ways around problems
and navigate hiccups in your quest
progression
and this is something that baldur's gate
3 seems to excel at
even in its early access not once in my
15 hours of playing have i encountered a
quote
fail state that i wasn't able to work my
way around
be that through some clever exploration
dialogue choices
approaching with different characters or
in one or two cases
violence
the systemic storytelling and gameplay
of baldur's gate 3 means that the game
almost
scabs over any damage you may deal to it
or any cuts you make into its narrative
threads
one small but interesting example of
this is when i encountered lyzelle
trapped in a cage on my second run
on the next meeting the tieflings
guarding her had been in combat with the
bandits that i'd convinced to leave the
ruins that i wanted to explore
but the male tiefling died in a battle
that happened completely without my
knowing
in this case i noticed that the dialogue
had been written unvoiced from multiple
perspectives
just in case an issue like this may
occur during the first meeting the
conversation would involve both
tieflings while in this instance the
game just kept on trucking with the one
remaining taking the lead
that allowed me to progress seemingly
without any major hitches
in a way that felt so organic that i
would have had no idea
that anything was different if i hadn't
already visited that section once before
now if i took on those quests and
actions in a different order perhaps
freeing lyzelle
before i spoke to the bandits things
would have played out in a new direction
as well
again this was a pretty minor example of
the system in action but that doesn't
make it any less interesting
especially as the rest of the game is
built in the same way and i couldn't
help but go back to thinking about
previous rpgs and how
this quest or dialogue may have broken
if this were any other title
this also speaks to the replayability
larian is aiming for with both the early
access version of baldur's gate 3 as
well as the final game
with that in mind i want to talk about
the absolutely daft number of options
that were available to you out in the
world
and when interacting with npcs that
inhabit it there are unique dialogue
options available depending on your race
class background and whether you're
tapping into your illified powers
as well as the combination of all those
working in tandem and that's before we
even get into the possibility of
communicating with the dead
or the wildlife
how about this you can stay if you keep
those ugly feet on the ground
these trees are mine follow the rules
and i won't have to intervene
got it even something as seemingly
simple as a locked door can be taken on
in a staggering number of ways
from lock picking stealing keys using
eldritch powers to smash the thing down
teleporting through a hole in the wall
or jumping in via the roof i've honestly
yet to be disappointed when it comes to
thinking
hmm i wonder if this will work there are
also other ways that a supposed fail
state can be conquered
or even the potentiality of one can be
minimized you can initiate contacts and
conversations or interact with the world
with any of your characters
not just your created one which in turn
allows you to tap
into the more beneficial racial traits
and stats if you fail a check on an
inanimate object
you can switch to a new character and
thus potentially create another
opportunity to try again
if you don't like the way a conversation
is going you can still manipulate the
rest of your party outside of that chat
and put them into some more advantageous
positions or manipulate the world as the
conversation continues
with this element in particular seeming
to carry over many inspirations from
divinity original sin
now knowing that a borked dice roll
isn't going to change things and that
even a high chance of success
isn't a guaranteed win also made me much
braver and more open to the ideas of
taking risks
and trying new options while exploring
bg3 in previous rpgs i would usually
pick any option or event that would
grant me the highest chance of success
or grant me the opportunity to see as
much of the content as i could
but knowing that it wasn't quite as
black and white as that in baldur's gate
3
options that were riskier narratively
interesting or that i thought
suited my character became much more
alluring and exciting
again that feels like something very d
tapping into the story and playing on
the background you created yourself
all while the game drip feeds you
opportunity after opportunity
to continue stories dialogue and
narratives
both on the macro and micro level
reaffirming the player that there are so
many options here
before you delve into becoming a murder
hobo
although if you want to play that way
you do you
you made a potential threat into a
certain one
we don't need to pick every fight the
approach boulders gate 3 takes to
success and failure really
is quite a refreshing one and something
i am really excited to see built upon
when you factor in its depth at this
early stage in its production
and add on the scope that larian wants
the game to be i really can't see a
situation
where your options are going to be found
lacking they're only going to become
more numerous
as time goes on and it's no surprise
that it's recommended
you run through the early access version
more than once as you would be hard
pressed to have the exact same
experience
every time i want you to go into
baldur's gate 3 not thinking of failure
as failing instead it's more of a hidden
option
in a dialogue tree that will allow you
to progress your experience even in the
face
of the number one on your dice it just
might not progress in the way you expect
it to
or in the way you want it to and after
all a hero or adventure that has nothing
but winds and victories in it
doesn't make for the most exciting tale
to tell down the tavern
my friend every story benefits from a
dragon
until we meet again that's been my main
takeaway from bowlers gate 3 so far in
the
just shy of 20 hours that i've got to
play it but i'd love to know what you're
excited for when it comes to traveling
across faerun and the sword coast there
is a lot to tap into in bg3 so we've got
plenty more content planned
so to be sure you don't miss out on that
make sure you hit the subscribe button
down below and let your thoughts be
known down in the comment section my
name is dave you can find me and all my
rpg ramblings over on twitter at a
regular dave and until next
time thank you so much for watching
you